Continental Tire Coaches Corner Florida
Atlantic miles go from 3 and 9 to 9 and
3 next game is this Saturday against
North Texas and we just had a quiz
during the commercial break Pauli goes
where is Florida Atlantic University and
I said all right well they're on the
Atlantic side of Florida fritzy said
Orlando that's incorrect my geography
skills aren't that great yeah but you
graduated number two in your class no I
was able to get away from the geography
stuff it's not even near the ocean
Fort Myers in Sarasota and then I said
Boca Raton you're correct in yes you're
owls Thank You miles Lane Kiffin joins
us now how's morale there coach awesome
kids are having a blast
she was a one eight eight games in a row
pretty pretty easy to have fun doing
that what did you think what were the
expectations when you went there there
were many expectations around here you
know because they really had never won
had been the full game in ten years and
I think that one can beat one winning
team in three years so the expectations
were really low but that didn't matter
that wasn't our expectations you know
when you come to a place like that you
know the number one goal is you had to
change the way people think you got to
make them think the way it's used to
thinking being around championship teams
how surprised were people that you took
that job considering you know you left
Alabama and you were going to Florida
Atlantic and you probably had to explain
what Florida Atlantic was and where it
was well I think you know for people
that you know looked at it I think there
was a lot of oh he's just trying to be a
head coach again so you just take any
job and it was not that at all because I
knew that you know I'm not naive that
the next job that I take is a head coach
if I don't win the storyline for my
career he probably is oh he's a good
offensive coordinator and won a bunch of
championships score about your points
but he's not a good head coach and
that's why your last shot so when I
looked at this job after meeting with
them the meeting with the president who
had come here from Clemson they had a
plan it had a plan to give us you know
what we needed
to build a championship program and
that's what we've done explain to me
what is going on with you and Nick Saban
uh not much doesn't respond to my text
messages does he know how to text he is
he is old on that and so yes this whole
thing about you never set of text in his
life that's nothing to do with meat
that's just you be the number one
recruit in the country he just doesn't
text and he just has this old-school
philosophy that I'm not going to give in
a texting so he doesn't doesn't text
doesn't tweet doesn't do those things
what's nothing wrong and said that's
just how he is what's your relationship
like oh good you know we left on
Wednesday perfect but you know when you
have the last twenty six times we walked
on a football field together we were 26
and oh you know one came together when
he hired me and said he wanted to change
his offense and thought they'd become
stale and old school and so I think we
did that three SEC championships you
know three playoff well three years and
three SEC offensive players of the year
I caught a pretty successful marriage
does he miss you I don't know if he
misses me maybe I'm not third down the
other night but the rat poison is I mean
it feels like you're trolling him a
little bit there with the rat poison
comment are you having a little bit of
fun with Coach Saban
he doesn't see it so you guys think I'm
trolling him even know what Twitter is
so he certainly doesn't retweeting it
yeah but his daughter has to say to him
hey Dad by the way this is what Lane
sent today somebody's got to be doing ad
now this is what it is he's the best
motivator in the world and what I don't
know if you guys realized when you guys
you know he complains that you guys and
goes off on his tangent about you guys
are rat poison seems so good and
everything
she loves that because he's using that
no yes I've been there he's using that
in the team meeting later that day to
tell everybody don't believe it don't
buy into this rat poison don't listen to
you guys no he's using that and so I'm
doing the same thing I just do in a
different way
I'm doing the same thing I just tell our
players you know our fans via Twitter
you know not listen to the rat poison he
just does it as do you mean he's link
lane kiffin Florida Atlantic head coach
joining his Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
have you been in touch with Tennessee
you or your people been in touch with
Tennessee I've talked to a few of the
people back there that I'm close to it
that our friends that you know we had a
great time that year together
I have not talked to the director Jimmy
sexton's my agent so when it you know
wouldn't you know how those things go
and they first come down they talk to
the agents and you know John curry you
know made it clear I guess Tim who he
was interested in and Jimmy had Greg
Schiano also and and so knew I'd go
there get the Homer and decided to do
that driving so I have not as much do
you think that's not a lot about this
because I have not thought of all
because number you know John Curry never
expressed any interest can you describe
what the last hours were like when you
were Tennessee's head coach interesting
that's for sure you know I tried to do
something that was very unique and like
kind of everything I do even though I
mean while it gets taken the wrong way
when you and my agent and everyone
around said hey just get on a plane and
get the USC that's what everybody does
they don't meet with the media the press
conference is at their new place and
then they explain things I said you know
what the tennessee media was awesome to
us our one year there so I said I'm
doing something different I just want to
explain to these guys because they don't
know I want them to be the first one to
know off-camera sit down with you know
the ten twelve main people there so I
said get him in a room and I want to
explain why I'm going home you know
dream job you know all three kids born
in California memory
you know almost one in three straight
national championship so I wanted to
explain that to them in that backfire
because one of the people said oh no
we're gonna put a camera in here and
then this ID got an argument with them
and so I don't know it all made it look
bad I was actually trying to do
something very unique
those guys they have been really good to
us we worried about your safety no I
wasn't worried about my safety that gets
a little bit the burning of the
mattresses and also if I could see that
out of window but I would not I wasn't
worried for my safety because all that
does and I said it in that next day that
is not negative that's the passion of
the SEC especially Tennessee they're
passionate I said before if they were
having a party when you left that's a
bad thing
that's a good thing because it means
they really like going on and they knew
we're gonna win a lot of games there so
I took it as a positive what's your
dream job now no I know I've got I've
gotten older so now you just say where
you're right of course you do
yeah but if I talked to you a couple
years ago then you probably actually
have a destination a different
destination it really it was USC and
that's like anything it's like there's
ago when you were a child if you grew up
in a certain area you know and you'll
say where's the favorite place you lived
it's usually somewhere when you were
young and so as a coach you know I was
really young it's basically almost where
I started was USC that was there were
six years of Pete Carroll and you know
we went to five straight BCS games and
played for three national championships
and won five conference championships so
three highs and winners so that was my
memory of USC and my thought was okay
three kids born there you know know the
area so many friends advanced with so
many friends are there that hey why we
can go back and do the same thing if I
was there from day one with Pete Carroll
why can't we just follow the same exact
recipe and have this names cuz he did
well here's a little wild card you know
when I was interviewing these two no
we're fine it might be one or two
scholarships at most what we get there
we take the job and all of a sudden into
LA hits us with the death penalty
30 scholarships lost to both went to
boat people or seen we couldn't play in
bowl games for two years from every
junior and senior on our roster could
leave immediately without penalty that's
unheard of you know Delhi times the next
days talking about basically the death
penalty and get ready for 40,000 people
in the Coliseum and three for win
seasons like what happened at Miami when
they got basically the same penalty
years ago and we managed through that to
go 2815 you know have winning seasons
every year go ten and two on your and
but everyone forgot about that so give
me the likelihood give me rank rank just
have some fun with me entertainment if
you can hear Raiders USC Tennessee the
likelihood that you would go to back to
any of those places what would be number
one two and three on that list come on
this won't make social media no it won't
make it by the time or even hang up no I
can't answer that one we I do know this
I look at all the places whether it any
good bad indifferent as where I am today
I'm a way better coach than where I was
back then because of all the places I
went especially one that you dad lost
Alabama because I worked for the the
greatest coach in the history of college
football for three years and got to
learn from him oh I didn't think that
was on the list I didn't think there was
any chance of going back to Alabama I
was trying to look at the likelihood of
the other three hey great to talk to you
I can hear your voice you're having fun
your team's nine and three you got North
Texas coming up this weekend thanks for
joining us Lane you got it Dan have a
great weekend that's Lane Kiffin
my Al's Florida Atlantic University and
I thought maybe he would give me the
priority list they're going back to the
Raiders yeah USC Tennessee
you know Tennessee might be number one
on the list as crazy as that may sound
with what's going on now but he said
that nobody's reached out to him I
haven't heard anything but I thought it
might be fun just to see if that was
possibility effort select multiple
references to the third down struggle
that he might have been I like the fact
that he's trolling saving but he saving
doesn't respond to any of his tweets but
he knows the message is probably being
delivered there Continental Tire coaches
corner from Sun to rain to snow and
everything in between continental tires
you engineered has an engineered tired
for you and what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more info in
the location of a dealer near you visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do or for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]